welcome back to pearson i said so what
is a university
what is it
i mean it used to be a place
that our bright young minds would go to
to expand those minds to be challenged
to take risks to take part in rigorous
debate with people who may implacably
disagree with them and then maybe reach
a point of consensus and go and have a
beer together have some fun that was
what universities used to be about but
look at what they've become
they've become these cotton wool bubble
wrapped hellholes
where the enemy is free speech
where there's a charge for safe spaces
where everyone gets triggered
what does that even mean to be triggered
by something you might read or hear
certainly my generation doesn't
understand what that means
so what is going on at our universities
well a shocking new report by the higher
education policy institute heppy
revealed the dramatic and disturbing
surges support for censorship by
students safe spaces protection from
alternate viewpoints
this is all among young students and of
the thousands who were surveyed nearly
two-thirds of them 61
were opposed to unlimited free speech
compared with just 37 in the exact same
survey in 2016.
17 only said they supported ensuring
unlimited free speech on campus although
events may occasionally be allowed and a
staggering 86 of them endorse the use of
trigger warnings so they can be
protected from coursework that might
upset them more than a third of the
students believe their teachers should
be fired for exposing them to any
material they find offensive which is
double the number in 2016
39 believe the student union should ban
all speakers who might cause offense and
76 were universities to get rid of any
statues or memorials to historical
figures they find problematic which of
course by their yardstick is now pretty
much everybody you might remember the
scenes in the blm protest in 2020 in
parliament square
where statues of winston churchill
nelson mandela and mahatma gandhi all
have to be boarded up lets the mob come
for them
so my view is this is all completely
nuts but i'm joined now by larissa
kennedy the president of the national
union of students who presumably i'm
good good evening to you by the way i
know you've had a tough journey from
croydon uh every every journey from
drawings and stuff right look i have to
say that joke was henry um you're free
you wish you were the same school
susanna reid indeed okay well i'll i'll
take that as a warning
a trigger warning
look this report to me was incredibly
damaging
you're representing the national union
student what's going on at our
universities why are you you'll become
the enemy of free speech why do you all
get triggered by everything why have you
all become such snowflakes interesting
that you want to position students as
enemies of free speech when it's the
very opposite in fact this report shows
that so many students are welcoming the
idea of a free speech champion but also
are welcoming the idea that we can hold
multiple truths that yes we have to
uphold freedom of speech but we also
need to put in place protections to make
sure that our campuses are a safe space
for the evolving people what does that
mean what does it mean and if you want
to ask what that means it means that
when you've got someone who has views
that are obviously going to spark
outrage but you give a heads up to the
people coming these are common sense uh
kind of things that you might be talking
about and in fact if i may finish my
point
when you talk to people
in local communities when you talk to
ordinary people and you talk about the
real realities of these measures that
students are suggesting like giving a
heads up to people or like um you know
helping facilitate protests and so on
people on the ground agree that these
are just common sense things to avoid
i don't know who you're talking to but
they don't
know who you're talking about most
people think this is all completely
cracked
what is crackers well let me go ahead
let me get through what do you need
trigger warnings for about stuff you may
read or stuff a professor may say why do
you need trigger warnings
what happens you literally have this
this sound i think this is a pretty red
obviously you don't do that i think what
we're seeing here is actually what the
report warns about it's people like you
who are creating these kind of
information inflammatory headlines and
responses to what is i just read the
report no no no
the sound played out in classrooms
that's not what's happening in
universities
if it was a joke it wasn't very funny
that was a joke you may not find my
humor funny but it was intended as a
joke
however i do not understand the concept
of a trigger warning for something you
may read or hear at university the whole
point of university is to be challenged
to be critical and in fact it's not a
challenge it's students who are no it's
about learning how to be critical of the
things that you see and hear and absorb
around you and in fact it's students who
are standing up and talking and
the purpose of an education is not to
produce here's what ricky gervais said
about free speech tell me if you think
he's wrong if you don't believe in free
speech with people who you disagree with
and even hate for what they stand for
then you don't believe in free speech no
you don't but if you don't believe that
freedom of speech has the legal
limitations that it has always had in
democratic countries when it comes to
the equalities act and other forms of
limits that have been always put on
freedom of speech and you also don't
believe in freedom of speech you believe
in freedom from consequence and those
are different things i don't i think i
think you should be absolutely held to
the fire there should be consequences
what you say and you should be
challenged and there should be debate
what i can't get my head around is that
86
of students now want trigger warnings on
course content which might upset
students all we're really saying here is
that it's going to note what's in the
course
what would you find
what would you like to are you against
people would you find that you're
against let me ask you
let me ask you what would you find too
triggering to read give me an example i
can't give you a personal example
because it's not my interest
this is students who are just saying
tell me what i'm tell me what's on the
course that's what a course list is
that's what a book list is that's the
word bibliography is it's not a big deal
and the fact that you're making it into
a big deal is exactly what it says what
is it bad faith actors if i may continue
you have bad face actors um who are
stirring up division around this when so
many organizations most of whom usually
disagree are saying this is a non-issue
and then you have to ask the question
why do we have so much airtime on this
why do we have so many people pouring
money and resources particularly so our
government into talking about this and
when you see it in the context of the
policing bill of all of the other bills
that are coming through that are
incredibly draconian you have to ask the
question who is benefiting from this
conversation because it's not students
the students are welcoming freedom of
speech and that's exactly what this
report says it said they well no
actually
it actually says the complete opposite
it says that if you read it that way of
course it doesn't no no the daily mails
it was literally actually i read it in
the times there was exactly okay there
was the exact same survey done six years
ago same questions and they published
the results it shows language it shows a
massive increase in the number of
students who want to censor it's not
free speeches it's about holding
multiple truths and the fact that
you've got such a reductionist
reductionist diluted conversation around
freedom of speech
clearly you're not
actually we know that's what's happening
universities and why was the last time
you went to university peers uh the last
time you're a student i was a student
when i was 19. oh how old are you that's
a long time ago that was a long hard
time
could i say that you're being aged yeah
i'm just saying wow that's a fact it was
a long time ago
no can you hear me
what i'm saying is how can you know
what's going on at our university i'm
just reading this report you're reading
a report that says that students welcome
the freedom this is the higher education
policy that says that students want to
make sure that yes there is freedom of
speech but also that we're enabling
support for students um who can ask a
question
can ask a question without you getting
offended i'm not offended right you
don't offend me if you're trying
okay great great go ahead
there's only one truth
facts or facts that's sick that's not a
very good philosophical outlet maybe you
should go maybe you
do you agree there's only one truth to
answer your question what does it mean
it means that it's both possible to
enable freedom of speech as our students
unions do day in and day out um but that
it is also possible to make sure that
we're hearing the voices of people um
who you know are our campuses on our
communities of education are often the
homes of these students as well so when
they're saying i want to have the space
to speak out about what's happening here
i want to have the space to protest i
want to have the space to share
alternative views that is them
exercising their democratic right to
freedom of speech too that's all fine
but let me bring in teresa purcell she's
the former president of the young
americans for freedom in buffalo before
we speak to teresa i want to just play a
clip this is what happened she invited a
prominent black republican lieutenant
colonel alan west to speak at the
university of buffalo on a subject
called america is not racist why
american values are exceptional during
the during the q a session protesters
began chanting and banging on the walls
west who was the the speaker was
escorted by police out of the event
protest protest continued outside uh
teresa you were with west and the police
escort you got separated the protesters
chased you into a bathroom where you had
to hide for hours as they shouted go
getter and we're screaming we've got a
bit of footage we can't actually see you
in it but here's a bit of the footage
from what was an alarming experience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so teresa i remember i remember this
incident i remember thinking god a young
woman who invites a speaker is basically
in fear of her life from a mob
that is behaving in such a shameful
manner what was it like for you and what
do you think of this whole report that's
come out in the uk
about more and more students wanting to
censor free speech
hi pierce thank you so much for having
me on uh the overall experience was
really terrifying i hosted colonel west
since a lot of colleges in the united
states and it might be similar in the uk
only host one side of the political
spectrum they only host speakers on the
left so with the help of young americans
foundation i wanted to bring a
conservative speaker to campus to talk
about these important issues of race and
american exceptionalism and i think that
the report that came out recently that
shows that college students are not
supportive of free speech is very
alarming and i saw this on my own
college campus by just trying to host a
speaker that they didn't agree with they
tried to run me off campus and tried to
terrify me and i was afraid for my life
as over 200 protesters were chasing me
and as you said i had to hide in a men's
bathroom and call the police as they
were shaking doors and screaming go get
her go get her capture her capture her
we need to get therese so overall i find
it really concerning that students don't
value free speech as they seem to only
value speech that fits their narrative
and don't want to hear from the imposing
side which is what college is all about
is having those debates right well thank
you teresa so loris i come back to you i
mean i presume you find that footage
appalling do you
what i find is that the the the ways in
which we talk about footage like that is
is concerning and appalling they
literally chased a young woman into a
men's wrestler so what happened
do you not find that watching that from
watching that what i've seen is that a
speaker spoke and students also spoke
and that's why they physically
manhandled them out of them
i heard no justice no peace which is a
very familiar you think that footage and
what happened to her is accepted i don't
have a particular position on that
footage because first of all it's not
from the uk and that's not my that's not
my territory right but first of all i
would say it's a harmful to try and
transpose an example from the us onto
the uk because here our students unions
are regulated by the charity commission
they have several measures in place that
ensure that they uphold freedom of
speech we have speeches with speakers
from across the political space one in
ten students in this survey so they
wanted to ban
uh conservative speakers yeah and
countless students also similar numbers
said that they also wanted to ban labour
and the green party and whoever were out
why are they banning do you know what it
is why are they banning any of them if
we're going to be honest peers it's
probably the president of the tory
society saying kick out labor the
president of the labour society saying
kick out tory the numbers are small do
you
do you agree that nobody like that
should be banned you should be hearing
all voices who's been talking about
banning who's been talking about banning
except the people 39
but in in reality i'm not asking hang on
let me finish 13 not you said that you
asked me a question i'm answering it 39
in the survey believe the students
unions should ban all speakers who calls
offense
why don't you want speakers to come and
be offensive and then take them on and
prove them wrong damn them with facts is
that not what students were doing in the
no they were chasing women into
restrooms
they were shouting go get protest
literally what they did we just heard it
she called the police saying no justice
no please
she literally had to call the police
okay so you're saying something i
disagree with i'm charting no justice no
peace is that a problem to you
you can tell what you like what you
can't do what you can't do is chase a
young woman into a men's restroom and
shout out go get it in an intimidating
threatening manner both of those things
are exercising freedom of speech let me
ask you what is a safe space
at university what is the same way again
this is the kind of thing
this is the kind of language that gets
picked up by the media and spun into
something that it's not really it's your
generation
first of all let's clear the right is
the safe space it was not
how do you know either wrong
no this is not safe
no please no
but
first of all i want to clear the record
because i did not make an aegis joke i
just said you went to uni a long time
ago if you were impressed by it yeah
but what is a safe space are you
suggesting i have mental health issues
no i'm suggesting you should talk to a
therapist about your issues i think
you're making a joke about my mental
health
you are triggering a lot of things here
you see how easy it is to trigger
a serious question yes i'm tired
what is a safe space
a safe space is about producing
somewhere it could be student-led it
could just be a group of friends it
could be whatever you make of it but
where you feel safe period this isn't
the name why do you feel so unsafe
you've just in this country are you
crazy
of course i feel unsafe in this country
you just said that that woman who was
literally barricaded into a men's
restroom that you were perfectly fine
with that i did not say i was perfectly
fine with it you didn't consider the
people
no justice no peace you just literally
talked about safe space wanting
protection of something when she wanted
it you said she's a conservative thing
is not to support the other the
alternative that's not please don't put
words in my mouth i don't appreciate it
what i did is i said that students
chanting no justice no peace whether
that's in the uk the us or elsewhere is
them exercising their freedom of speech
okay
that's what i said full story
what what is your idea of free speech
final question my idea of free speech
yes
is people being able to express
themselves whether that's through
speakers on campus whether that's
through protests you know students have
always exercised freedom of speech you
know whether it's the fact that nus was
the first organization national
organization in the country to come out
in support of lgbt rights whether it's
the fact that students now speak so
proudly in support of trans rights and
black liberation and climate justice
students have always spoken about do you
allow for example on our campuses would
you allow jk rowling for example to get
our campuses in our communities if i may
finish my point
last question you said but now you're
adding another one
so when people are you know standing out
on picket line supporting the rmt or ucu
or any other union when they're doing
that students have always been at the
forefront
we've always faced backlash for it and
we're not going to stop in my opinion
you're the snowflake because i'm so
impressed about it i understand would
you allow jk rowling to come to any
university what kind of question is that
would you like to try to have power to
stop people from coming to uni would you
wanted to but what you're the president
of the nus would you want jk rowling
what kind of questions
should she be allowed to speak at
university you answer it then what kind
of question
the vast majority of speaker events in
the uk that are student-led
questions are run by student societies
who are elected simple questions and
they simply go to their students how
would you support them facilitate that
simply ask how would you feel it's not
for me to just ask your personal opinion
on campus what's your opinion well i'm
representing my members i'm not giving
you enough impersonal this ain't
personal okay well i'm gonna i'm about
to debate in a minute uh this issue of
what is a woman what is a woman
what what's that got to do with the
price of friends piers i literally told
you i'm about to debate this
what is a woman what do you mean austin
i said ask the next girl do you know
what a woman is a woman is someone who
defines us as a woman period done not
anyone next guest anyone okay i'm a
woman is that yeah i said next guest
because that's not my secret if i if i
said my word i know you're trying to
trap me and i'm not falling if i say i'm
a woman do you agree i'm a woman
i said
next guest because i'm not falling for
it bye you're not getting your little
clip out of me your little audio about
me without realizing it you may have
just given me my little clip that's the
point that's wonderful that ironically
is the clip that's wonderful because
when young women can't actually say what
a woman is i think it's mad i'm a woman
i'm a young woman who's very proud
i'm very proud
who support free speech who work hard to
make sure that our students anybody who
says there are women
who exercise their democratic right to
protest and do so in a way that is in
line with the law larissa great to see
you i wish i could say the same piece
goodbye well i'm sorry it wasn't such a
safe space for either of us but we got
through it it's okay it's over thank god
all right go enjoy your trip back to
coin
you